[Music]
the conclusion to the lords of shadow
saga exhibits peaks of brilliance and
art direction and sound design and its
new free camera system is a definite
improvement over the first games tightly
choreographed camera however to fully
enjoy the best parts within you must
endure a handful of drab settings and
boring stealth puzzles along the way at
times is enough to make you want to put
the controller down especially after the
story's puttering take off but stick
around until the end and you'll enjoy
eye catching boss fights and a
satisfying conclusion to the narrative
that ultimately reduces the negative
impact of the games earlier issues the
Prince of Darkness Dracula is in a tough
position at the start of lords of Shadow
two centuries into his tenure as the
lord of vampires he suffers under the
weight of immortality and the memories
of his once beloved family that is until
he awakes in a Cathedral smack dab in
the middle of a modern metropolis
shortly thereafter he's confronted by
his arch nemesis
Sobek who betrayed Dracula centuries
earlier though Beck's quest for world
domination has hidden obstacles
Satan is on the rise this all comes
after a rousing prologue set in the past
which sees Dracula full-strength
battling righteous warriors in and
around his unholy castle for all the
excitement offered there the true start
to lords of Shadow two's plot with xot
back is comparatively deflating your
motivation to hunt someone else's
enemies doesn't inspire excitement or
interest plus you're immediately thrust
into one of the most bland and
uninspiring settings to be found an
industrial scientific complex replete
with sheetmetal red pipes and security
guards as the game carries on however
Dracula finds himself back in time and
the gameplay returns to its roots combat
and tormented environments take center
stage and with the game's new free
moving camera and an emphasis on
exploration both aspects feel fresh and
new
the first lords of Shadow 2 Castlevania
into the realm of God of War style
combat with an emphasis on combining
direct and wide attacks but a rewarding
parrying system it's largely the same
this time around - but there are a few
new tools to play around with along with
a rewarding skill mastery system and
lords of Shadow - you learn skills for
each of your three weapons independently
skills are learned by spending
experience points granted during combat
when each skill has a gauge that fills
with use the fragmentation of the move
lists delays your efficacy in battles
somewhat but it also allows you to focus
on customization more than before each
weapon features a wide swath of skills
to learn opening the game up to
different types of combat strategies
when you aren't smashing demon skulls
you spend quite a lot of time exploring
your environment by default your
objective is often highlighted on your
map hints like swarms of bats tip you
off to handholds for climbing and ledges
for leaping however unlike the first
game there are many alternate paths to
explore in search of treasure while not
entirely game-changing the openness
feels appropriate given the wide world
around you apart from some occasionally
frustrating path finding only the map
stands in your way
it's only ever represented on a piece by
piece basis then the larger world map is
just an illustration with names and
numbers attached it doesn't hurt the
moment-to-moment poking around but it
doesn't entice you to backtrack either
and besides the deeper you get into
lords of Shadow 2 the better it gets
halfway through the game the narrative
and frequency of impressive set pieces
begins to steamroll ahead and the last
thing you want to do is look back zou
Beck takes a side line to Dracula's
ambitions and you and he begin to
understand why he's really going to such
great lengths to thwart Satan can that
point on you spend almost every minute
around and within sublime examples of
Gothic architecture
it's a pleasing change of pace after
slogging through boring environments
waiting for something to grab your
attention the contrast between the two
halves of the game is really hard to
ignore and even though you have to force
your way through mediocrity to get to
the good stuff the conclusion and a few
hours leading up to it justify the time
spent steeped in boredom in frustration
realizing this it's clear that lords of
Shadow 2 could have been a much shorter
game still though its stealth sections
and drab modern settings represent the
worst elements of the three-part saga
the tail end of the game contains the
very best of every aspect even better
the final act wraps up the lords of
shadow trilogy with authority and the
game's final breaths leave you both
gasping for air and sighing in relief
it may not strike newcomers to Gabriel's
tail with such force but it's
nonetheless a surprising and fulfilling
conclusion to the singular chapter of
lords of Shadow 2 if you have the
patience to get through the rough start
you'll discover a much better game
waiting for you on the other side
[Music]